when our administration basically says
hey we're not going to really protect
the border
people start pouring in then when people
start pouring in what happens well in a
place like a border town of texas a
far-right latina
some far right latina
mayra flores wins what was a democrat
seat for a hundred years because people
have had it and people want legal
immigration not illegal immigration and
then what happens well finally when
enough people realize that people are
pouring through the border that no one
is in charge of this
suddenly the media two years too late
again that's the theme that the media
always the media and the quote-unquote
sane dems they always catch up way too
late then they start asking questions
here's nbc's chuck todd asking kamala
about the border this is just a day or
two ago would you call the border secure
i think that there is no question that
we have to do what the president and i
asked congress to do the first request
we made
pass
a
bill
to create a pathway to citizenship the
border is secure but we also have a
broken immigration system in particular
over the last four years before we came
in and it needs to be fixed we're gonna
have two million people cross this
border for the first time ever you're
confident this border's secure
we have
a secure border
in that that is a priority for any
nation including ours in our
administration
she is so extraordinarily vapid like
that's the only thing you could say
about her right it's like man between
her and binding it's like biden doesn't
know what he's saying and we'll just
read anything with her it's as if they
put her out there having no knowledge of
anything and she strings together words
in the most circular way to say
absolutely
nothing chuck is doing the best job he
could there hey a lady you know two
million people are coming in that's an
awful lot of people uh
this thing's secure and then she just
says well we have a policy of a policy
and it's a policy blah blah blah okay so
again the cause and effect situation
here is in full effect bad policies lead
to crazy things happening and then crazy
things actually then reverberate when a
crazy thing happens at the federal level
it may start in a border town of texas
but then it reverberates throughout the
nation